- It’s-a me, Mario!
It’s-a me, Mario!
Woo-hoo, let’s-a go!
Okey dokey!
Ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow!
I've been the voice of Mario for 26 years.
- [Interviewer] Now moving on to Luigi.
- Now moving on to Luigi, oh.
(laughing)
("Super Mario Overworld
Theme" by Koji Kondo)
Hi, I'm Charles Martinet.
I do the voice of Super
Mario, here we go, woo hoo!
And Luigi too, Luigi number one, ho ho!
And Wario, have a rotten day.
Yah-ho!
You gonna eat that garlic?
(laughs)
and I was even Donkey Kong at one point.
Oh hoo hoo!
I am an actor and voice actor.
I did gosh, 25 years of theatre.
Run along to your party!
Corporate videos.
Circuitry and semi-conductor processes.
A few film and television products.
Now beat it all of ya, now!
And then I had the marvelous beginning
of becoming a voice actor
and that's how I started
with it’s-a me, Mario!
Mario was first created in 1981
in a game called Donkey Kong.
As it got refined through the years,
it became Mario and Princess Peach.
Ah, the Princess!
And I came along in 1990.
I actually crashed an audition
because I was catching
them as I walked in they
were walking out finished
for the day and I said,
"can I read for this?"
And the guy looked at
his watch and he goes,
"ugh, alright, come on in.
"You're an Italian plumber from Brooklyn,
"a character in a video game for Nintendo
"called Mario so make up a voice,
"make up a video game, start talking."
And I thought to myself, video game?
I don't know anything about video games
and all of a sudden I hear action,
I go "hello, I’m-a Mario, let's
make a pizza pie together.
"You go get some-a sausage,
I’m-a go get some spaghetti,
"we put spaghetti and-a
sausage in the pizza."
And he said, "cut, stop
talking, there's no more tape,
"alright thanks, we'll be in touch."
And I thought that was, you know,
okay there's the door, we'll see ya later.
And he calls Nintendo, "I
found a Mario, I got him."
And that was 26 amazing
fantastic years ago.
Hello!
(laughs)
Whoo-pee!
Oh, look at this world.
The character for me
brings out the best in me
and so I love that.
Bing bing bing, (laughs)
I love sharing things too.
I go to meet Mario fans
and I hear the most wonderful things.
You know, you're the voice of my childhood
or I used to play with my dad,
now I'm playing with my kids.
It's a way our family comes together.
Ya ya ya ya ya, ha!
Ah, pretty good!
Ah, this brings back the memories.
Mama mia!
You just have fun, you know?
That's my mantra for life.
Come on, let’s-a go!
Let's have more fun!
Bye bye, see you in my gameses.
Woo-hoo!